lanza del vasto est mort à 81 ans lanza
del vasto ce nom ne vous dit peut être
rien pourtant cet écrivain italien fut
pendant plus de 40 ans l'une des figures
de la non-violence en france et en
europe
il s'agit de de faire une résistance au
mal et à l'injustice mais en employant
des moyens juste de façon à ne pas
redoubler la chaîne du mal un principe
qu'il découvrait à la fin des années 30
en inde auprès de gandhi il partagera
ensuite dans de nombreux écrits et
oeuvres artistiques mais aussi au sein
de la communauté de l'arche fondé avec
sa femme en 1954 dans le vaucluse un
groupement d'une centaine de personnes
tous réunis autour d'une même
philosophie de vie je désire et fonder
une communauté sur les bases de la
non-violence appliquée à tous les plans
de la vie non violence économique qu'est
ce que c'est n'exploiter personne ne
permettre à personne de nous exploiter
avaié pour pour le service et non pour
le gain au début des années 60 la
communauté des ménages est dans
l'hérault en bordure du plateau du
larzac et lorsqu en 1971 les paysans
l'art à quoi s'est levé contre
l'extension d'un camp militaire
lanza del vasto prenait aussi part au
combat en solidarité il entamait 15
jours de grève de la faim c'est un
devoir de bon voisinage nous habite dans
notre communauté est installé dans les
environs nous considérons que chez notre
devoir d'intervenir pour aider les
paysans à mener leur lutte
lanza del vasto les initiés aussi à une
nouvelle arme la non-violence un non
violence et la conversion de la colère
il faut avoir un tempérament de guerrier
pour pour entrer dans la non violence
avec efficace après dix ans d'un combat
pacifique acharné l'extension du camp
militaire sera finalement annulée en
1976 lanza del vasto était aussi auprès
des manifestants mobilisés contre le
réacteur nucléaire de creys malville
dans l'isère encore une fois la non
violence était selon lui le seul moyen
de contestation efficace on est en train
d'ouvrir un volcan artificiels entre
lyon et genève
nous demandons qu'il y à un moratoire
qu'il y ait une information sérieuse
faite par des experts qui ne soit pas
internationaux et s'en ressent la
pression gdf ni deux du gouvernement
français
cette fois la lutte fut vaine la
centrale nucléaire a été construit mais
la philosophie non violente de lanza del
vasto mort le 5 janvier 1981 inspirera
d'autres mouvements contestataires et
aujourd'hui elle fait toujours partie
des piliers des onze communautés de
l'arche fondé à travers l'europe
[Musique]